otra más se trata de la delantera
francesa Delfín cascaje y no quien se
une a las afectadas por las roturas de
ligamento cruzado anteriores selección
tan dura su Club en la liga francesa el
olan pick de León reveló la mala noticia
la jugadora de 26 años salió lastimada
el fin de semana en un partido por la
liga Gala y tras realizarse varios
estudios se conoció que presenta una
rotura parcial del ligamento cruzado
anterior derecho por lo que deberá
someterse a una cirugía y va a necesitar
de varios meses de recuperación se trata
de una baja sensible para las francesas
de Cara a ese mundial que arranca el
próximo 20 de Julio en Australia Nueva
Zelanda Maggie antoto no se ha
recuperado a tiempo de una rotura igual
que sufrió en julio del año pasado en
medio de la Eurocopa y lo tiene muy
difícil también para estar en el Torneo
pero es que además fuera de Francia Lía
williamson la capitana de Inglaterra
sufrió la misma lesión en abril y
tampoco irá a la copa mundo mismo caso
para la neerlandesa vivían mi edema y
también para la estadounidense Catarina
Macario no nos olvidamos por ejemplo de
Alexa putellas a doble ganadora del
Balón de Oro que apenas está recuperando
de otra lesión de otra rotura en el
ligamento cruzado anterior que es un
tema que tiene un poco que ver con la
preparación de los deportistas y con
discriminación y que espero podamos
abordar más adelante con mayor tiempo
Juan